but again that's what the world is like
people take everything personally i
think the
world revolves around them right
particularly on twitter right
i don't know i'm not tweeting anyone i'm
just tweeting okay i don't know who's
following me
i've got 12 million followers i don't
know who's following me they can be
following me without me knowing
right choose to read my tweet and then
take that personally
that's like going into a town square
seeing a big notice board
and there's a notice guitar lessons and
you go
but i don't [ __ ] want guitar lessons
what's this ah there's a number here all
right call that right
are you giving me guitar lessons yeah i
don't [ __ ] want any
fine it's not for you then just walk
away
don't worry about it i don't know if
you're affected by the
volcanic ash cloud um but i had friends
that were stuck all over
the world and they missed weddings and
funerals and they had to put themselves
up in a hotel
for extra days or they hadn't budgeted
for and they couldn't get their money
back because the airlines were saying no
we can't pay you because the insurance
companies won't pay us
because they're saying it's an act of
god
what isn't an act of god no
if you believe in god that's sort of a
definition of him isn't it
that he does everything isn't that right
everything is an act of him he's
all-powerful
he's everywhere at one he invented it
there was nothing before him
he invented time everything he's across
it all okay he doesn't miss a trick and
he's not absent-minded
a volcano going off isn't like him going
[ __ ] i left the oven on you know it's
i know are these insurance companies
that can decide what is and isn't an act
of god how do they know okay have they
got a hotline to god
they'd call him up do they ring-ring
ring-ring
hello uh could i speak to god please
speaking oh i didn't think you'd answer
the phone yourself do you want
oh um that volcanic ash cloud
uh was that you yeah
yes that was an act of me all right so i
shouldn't pay out no don't [ __ ] pay
him a penny son
no brilliant brilliant while i've got
you here
um did you make a tree fall on steve
baxter's car
there's a lot of steve baxter's um steve
baxter to acacia road
houndslow it happened at 2 15 on the
third of june this year
2 15 30 no that wasn't me
i was in africa that day giving aids to
[Applause]
babies
he does everything he does everything
i have never worked out the moral to
humpty dumpty
humpty dumpty sat on a wall humpty
dumpty had a great fall
all the king's horses and all the king's
men couldn't put humpty together again
all i can think is
don't sit on a wall if you're an egg
but again how is that applicable to a
five-year-old human
i mean you tell that to a group of five
oh so don't sit on a wall of your neck
what do you mean if i'm an egg i'm not
an egg
oh it doesn't make sense if i'm i'll win
none of us are eggs
if there was an egg there it wouldn't
make sense can you go to the egg
don't sit on the wall and go i'm an egg
i can't eat you i've got nothing
no ears no eyes i don't know what the
[ __ ] what
don't sit on what i can't [ __ ] hear i
don't i don't
i've got nothing this is i'm in
nothingness i can't [ __ ] climb walls
for a start
so
don't send horses to perform medical
procedures
[Laughter]
[Applause]
of course they couldn't put him together
again
they've got no dexterity whatsoever
they can't sew to save their life that
they've got no thumbs they're
learn opposable thumbs they don't send
send a [ __ ] it's a delica
an egg we've got a cracked egg should we
send a horse
definitely not have you got a doctor or
someone who works for faberge
don't
we we've we've we've got like a half a
ton creature with no fingers
no don't send that
got a four-legged thing we'd like no no
no chance
they they they can't they put couldn't
put on
they couldn't scrub up they can't
[Applause]
magic this isn't it delicate egg horse
comes over
[ __ ]
it couldn't they wouldn't even think of
[ __ ] that's it they wouldn't even see
it they'd go there
what the [ __ ] that's it wouldn't even
you couldn't explain it
to it don't send it
if i had to design the perfect egg
crushing device it would be a hoof
[Applause]
i need this uh as a cracked egg i need
it crushing completely
hoof the hoof's great
don't send off doesn't matter whether
the king's horses or not
don't certainly don't send all of them
that's gonna be chaos if there was one
horse with a little bit announced he had
a child he did like one year before he
got kicked out of harvard
he could have i know the rudimentaries
that are they all the [ __ ] ah for
[ __ ] sake
there's no lads don't dare they're
[ __ ] all over it
[ __ ] it's definitely [ __ ] now
[Applause]
what if we'd have been invaded by france
that day and they're all
bloke comes running up the hill because
are you in charge of all the king's
horses
all these men yep friends are coming
what the french are coming where are all
the king's horses i set them to mend an
egg you don't be gone what do you mean
you said demand a [ __ ] egg
ah if your surname is dumpty
don't call your firstborn humpty
[Applause]
what sort of stigma is that for a
kid that's already an egg
[Laughter]
and have a piss ripped out of him
i bet he jumped off the wall
we've come a long way from it being
punishable to total equality as it
should be of course in england the gauge
of consent same as heterosexuality now
um 16 and even gay marriage um although
ironically the one place that was really
ahead of the game fell behind a little
at the last
election california they had a
referendum they put it to the vote
and they voted no to gay marriage i mean
in california
there's people going that's why we moved
here i mean it's a
it's a strange sort of bigotry that you
can affect someone else's lifestyle that
doesn't affect you back
it's not like they asked a bloke once
said sorry um do you mind if these two
men get married he went no fine okay
jack them off then what i didn't know
that was good
that doesn't happen doesn't it that
doesn't happen
look it's also a strange sort of bigotry
because these people
that object to that were presumably the
same people that said you know
gay people were immoral and promiscuous
but now they don't want to be monogamous
and respectful in the eyes of god and it
must be so confusing to a gay guy in
california thinking
that's the bit they don't like with all
the other [ __ ] we get up to it's the
marriage bit that was so confused they
must go to judges and go
sorry can i get the rules straight what
do you want to know i just didn't know
what we can and can't do
ask away can i marry a man no
can i [ __ ] him up the ass and give him a
little reach round
[Applause]
please
i can't marry him no but
can i pick up a stranger in the bushes
and take him home and drizzle him and
throw him out in the morning or crusty
and homeless
of course you can yeah but i couldn't
marry him no
no and don't ask again
could i line up 15 men i'm just riffing
here
can i line up 15 men and just jack them
off
for a laugh if you want yeah
it would be difficult wouldn't it
jacking off 15 minute one it'd be like
plate spinning
wouldn't it no because you'd have you
could only do two at once really so
you'd have these two ready to blow but
then they'd be losing it and you'd
[Applause]
jacking off 15 men at once never thought
i'd say that oh
again um no
he was the ringleader old adolph
that name name's died out in it
[Applause]
he killed that dead didn't he no one's
calling their kid adolf nowadays no
little adults going to school loads of
brads and angelina's but no
that you don't hear the teacher doing
the register brad here angelina here
adolf here
i do that quick so no one can take a
picture of me doing that um
no but people make excuses for him
people say
oh he was stupid he was easily led he
didn't he didn't mean that what do you
mean he didn't mean that i say oh no
he's influenced by the political
philosopher friedrich nietzsche right
because nietzsche wrote this
paper um talking about a superman he
said
not all men are born equal and hitler
misinterpreted this and went
way too far with it and uh think of that
you're a great scholar you've done this
work and you get a call
from the fuhrer and the viewer goes
all right nietzsche yes yeah good what
do you want because
just read your book what do you think
love it
love all that man and superman not
everyone's equal kill all the jews sorry
[Applause]
[Laughter]
not everyone's equal so kid all the jews
i didn't like that
i read between the lines
[Applause]
i i i didn't mean that that's terrible
have you
you haven't yep you haven't been killing
jewish people have you
what
have you been in jewish people
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a few how many
six million six million that's all i
won't do anymore
leave it leave it at six that's terrible
i won't do any more
stay for dinner well i will but be
careful in future
i will are you writing any other books
well i am but i'm scared to tell you
about it
i won't do anything what's a new book
called my new book is called the gypsies
do we need them
[Applause]
there's these people that say being gay
isn't natural
well it is natural um and i've got a
book to prove it
um
homosexuality occurs in about the same
incident
in the animal kingdom as it does in
human society
this is a real book it's called
biological exuberance
animal homosexuality and natural
diversity by bruce bagamil
okay um the evidence is compelling and
it seems there is virtually no species
which does not have its gay community
that doesn't mean like chimps
on one particular street wearing leather
caps and stuff it's
they sort of spread it out more really
this is a real book can we have the
first slide please
right okay right
this is a real book okay
right absolutely real okay
two male stumptown macaques in mutual
fellatio
mutual they're sharing they're sharing
their own
next slide okay
a male squirrel monkey right performing
a genital display
toward another male uh
he's just going what do you think of
that
this one's going what
suck it
look at his little hand why
because we're gay i'm not you [ __ ]
are
look at the way he's holding him and
he's got his leg up for extra purchase
let's go get them there get in there
get in there look at him
can you imagine my face when i
discovered this book
next slide please ah okay a female
olympic marmot
mounting another female now
i don't know what is in that for either
of them
unless the one on top is wearing a
strap-on dildo
one more one more slide oh this is a
doozy
okay two forms of copulation
between male dolphins genital slit or
anal penetration above
and below blow hole penetration
oh yeah oh yeah
[Applause]
basically
he
is [ __ ] him
in the head it's in the head he's
[ __ ] him in the head
ladies i have never seen that on any
wildlife documentary i've never
why have i never seen that before
why are they doing that
maybe it's not in the wild maybe it's in
sea world which is like their prison
they're going they're going [ __ ] sake
they put in two males like some people
think we're fish we might as well
[ __ ] do it okay
i mean look at his face
he's going dave what
could could we could we not do up the
arse like them
no it's in the head or nothing
[Applause]
dave what what
dave dave i love you
but i can't [ __ ] breathe
[Applause]
that is a real book that is a real book
can we have it look
i love the fact that he found like a
turkey in drag
to to show how guy animals can be
the gayest animal in the world
i was talking earlier about um trying to
educate myself
and that is true and i think you know um
the internet is probably the greatest
resource of information the world has
ever seen
it's amazing and there are online
encyclopedias
that you can go into and change
you can't do that in the library can you
really you can't just get down inside of
peter what are you doing mate just
changing a bit
[ __ ] off
it's loads of websites just clogging up
the internet
by people they're doing websites about
themselves it's like
my name is rupert this is my cat i like
the cure
who gives a [ __ ]
[Applause]
and the trivia sites where do people
just load up things they've learned
and i just think what they wake up in a
cold sweat and go i've got to tell the
world this the peanut is not a nut it's
a legume
but my favorite my favorite are the
animal facts
the animal facts are just i think
incredible
this is from a website called devon
jen's
world of knowledge okay and i want you
to think about the people who put this
up okay
that you know not just the fact but who
did it and why they did it
what were they thinking okay number one
you can lead a cow upstairs but not down
thanks very much um
i looked into that it's true a cow will
go upstairs but they won't go downstairs
because the way their joints
don't oppose but i think of the poor
bastard who found that out the hard way
come on daisy down you go i don't go
downstairs
come on no i don't go downstairs i'm
away with joy i don't care about your
joints
my wife's coming home from work in five
[ __ ] minutes to get down the stairs
[Applause]
you thought yeah i've got to tell other
people about this
number two stroking a spider
can cause it to go bald
thanks one what sort of maniac goes
around stroking spiders
dracula's assistant i don't know
two is that a problem in the arachnid
world
premature balding do they worry about
that much i thought i'd be
they'd be loving it wouldn't they be in
the skinner they're so [ __ ] hard
got all the legs all the eyes the teeth
[ __ ] it i'm bored who cares
abs to it i like it more but no
apparently it's a big big problem you
stroke a little spider he goes oh my god
he runs back to the web and all the
other spiders go
what are you wearing a baseball cap for
fashion
[Laughter]
bit weird no it's just fashion
we'll take it off in the web now i'll
just keep it on
a bit cold cold
we're in a cupboard under the sink it's
boiling
ah take it off now take it off oh
[Applause]
have you been in a human stroke here
leave this [ __ ] web
number three
polar bears will sometimes cover their
black nose during a hunt
to camouflage themselves more completely
it's a good idea in it because uh apart
from the old nose a perfectly
camouflaged there white snow's white
so sneaking up on a little arctic hair
and i get there in the arctic hair he
turns around
the polar bear goes
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but how did they find out because that's
behavioral
all the polar bears sitting around one
night going i'm starving
every time i sneak up in a little hair
he looks round and he hops off it's like
he can
see me i can't work out little voice
little hair goes i can tell you
can you see us well i can see where you
are and how many there are
of you really
how
you'll kick yourself
now go on tell us
your nose is black the nose it's black
[Applause]
oh
cheers
[Applause]
can you see us now no
thank you
my favorite fact okay number four
montana mountain goats will sometimes
butt heads so hard that their hooves
fall off
can that be true that's amazing
[Laughter]
so there's two there they're looking at
a female goat one goes
i like her and then goes yeah i'm
probably gonna mate with her well now i
saw her first
that's not how it works how does it work
we have to run at each other really hard
and crack heads
is that safe oh yeah
[Laughter]
okay go do do
[Applause]
ow ow
oh look
yeah yours all right
yeah i grip on impact
did you know about this
why don't you tell me mortal enemies
never mind that my [ __ ] feet are
falling off
[Applause]
one more amazing fact
elephants have been caught swimming
up to two miles off the coast in the
indian ocean
that's amazing i didn't know they like
to swim i certainly didn't think they
could swim
two miles out to sea but it's the
language this person uses
have been caught swimming
[Applause]
like it's illegal
[Applause]
says the coast guard morning morning
morning foaming ring ring
hello they're doing what
no i'll be there
[Applause]
that's me in a little boat i'm not
jacking a bloke off behind me
what are you doing nothing
it's not nothing is it
what's that beach ball
tell me what you're doing
don't look at him what are you doing
swimming yeah
you are
do you know how far off coast you are
two miles is it yes it is yes it is
you know you're not meant to do this
don't you
don't cry
[Applause]
but if you know you're not meant to do
it
i've told you loads of times why are you
doing it again
i forgot farming
is a problem um
which brings me to this next pad that we
need to stamp out um
this happened christmas before last
exchanging gifts
uh with old friends good friends um
quite well off friends from being honest
um
i got them a coffee making machine from
harrods top of the range they loved it
um they gave me my present it was just
an envelope i thought oh what's this
vouchers
open it up it wasn't vouchers um it was
just a card with a picture of a goat on
it
um and i said what's this they went oh
our gift to you
is we gave a goat to an african family
what
i'm looking at the coffee machine thing
is it too late to take that back is it
too
i wasn't oh um we we gave a goat to an
african family
did you oh so
i've got [ __ ] all then basically
i mean i don't even know this african
family
why would i give them a go it doesn't
matter this serves no purpose
at all no but this is no good for anyone
they're 50 quid down
i've got nothing the african family's
going not another mouth to feed
right the goat is going
where the [ __ ] am i this what the
this is [ __ ] a week ago i was gambling
around the cotswolds there was
there was grass and tourists with nuts
and this is a [ __ ] dust bowl
and there's no way that goat wanted to
go to africa it was basically no it was
kidnapped it was
abducted it was put in a sack and
bundled on a boat to africa like roots
in reverse
there was no there was no way they went
you want to go to africa he went
definitely not no
no oh come on why didn't you want to go
to africa um
lions come on why didn't you want to go
to africa
um aids well that shouldn't affect you
it shouldn't
you're you'll be pleased to know this is
the last time
i'm hosting these awards so i don't care
anymore
um i'm joking i never did um
let's go out with a bang let's have a
laugh at your expense
shall we remember they're just jokes
we're all gonna die soon and there's no
sequel so
yeah remember that um but you all look
lovely
all doled up you came in your limos i
came here in a limo tonight and the
license plate
was made by felicity huffman so
no shush
it's a it's her daughter i feel sorry
for
okay that must be the most embarrassing
thing that's ever happened to her
and her dad was in wild hogs so
lots of big celebrities here tonight i
mean legends
icons yeah look at this table alone uh
al pacino robert de niro
baby yoda oh that's that's joe pesci
sorry
um i love you man don't have me whacked
um
but tonight isn't just about the people
in front of camera in this room are some
of the most
important tv and film executives in the
world people from
every background but they all have one
thing in common
they're all terrified of ronan farrow
he's coming for you he's coming for you
look talking of all you perverts it was
a big year
it was a big year for pedophile movies
um
surviving r kelly leaving neverland
two popes shut up shut up
i don't care i don't care
no one cares about movers anymore no one
goes to cinema no one really watches
network tv
everyone's watching netflix this show
should just be me coming out going well
done netflix you win
everything good night but no no we gotta
drag it out for three hours
you could binge watch the entire first
season of afterlife
instead of watching this show that
that's a show about a man
who wants to kill himself because his
wife dies of cancer
and it's still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end
he obviously didn't kill himself just
like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
do you like to make your own way here in
your own plane didn't you right
but seriously most films are awful lazy
remakes sequels i've heard a rumor
that there might be a sequel to sophie's
choice
i mean that'd just be meryl streep going
well it's gotta be this one then
the irishman was amazing it was amazing
um
it was my fac my f it was great
long but amazing um
it wasn't the only epic movie once upon
a time in hollywood nearly three hours
long
leonardo dicaprio attended the premiere
and by the end his date was too old for
him
even prince andrew is like come on leo
mate you know
you're nearly 50 son um
the world got to see james corden as a
fat [ __ ]
he was also in the movie cats but
no one saw that um and the reviews
are shocking i saw one that said this is
the worst thing to happen to cats
since dogs right
but dame judy dench defended the film
saying it was the role she was born to
play
because she i can't do this next joke
because she loves nothing better than
plonking herself down on the carpet
lifting her leg and licking her
[Applause]
verbal verbal she's old school
um
it's the last time who cares